what number is shown by the place value
blocks
so here we have several sets of place
value blocks some with many many many
blocks and some with just single blocks
stacked on top of each other
and we want to know what number is
represented by all of the blocks
combined
so let's start over here with the single
blocks stacked on top of each other
because it'll be the easiest one to
count
we can zoom in on that a little bit
make it easier for us to count and these
are just single blocks ones
stacked on top of each other
so we can count them and we'll see
there's one two three four five six
seven eight nine blocks
nine blocks right here
then moving over now we have columns of
ones
and each of these columns here's nine
because nine is even even with this
other nine column plus one more is ten
so each of these columns has ten blocks
these are
tens
how many tens do we have we have one two
three four five five sets of ten or
fifty
so we have 50 blocks here plus 9 more in
that last column
moving over
now we have these columns of 10 but it's
several columns of 10 stuck together to
make sort of like a slab
how many columns of 10 are in this slab
there's
1 2 3
4 5 6
7 8 9 10 columns of ten ten rows of ten
or ten columns of ten
which is a total of one hundred so each
of these slabs is a hundred
and how many slabs do we have we have
one
and then two a second one back there
so we have two hundreds or two
hundred
and then finally scooching it over a
little bit
here we have
these slabs of 100 these sets of 100
all stack together so there's one set of
100 here then another set behind it and
another and so on
so let's count how many hundreds this is
we have 100
200 300 400 500 600 700 800
900 and that last one makes it a
thousand
so these are
thousands
and how many thousands are there
there are
one
two so two thousand
two thousands
now zooming back out
we can look at all of the amounts we had
we had 2 000 blocks plus 200 more blocks
plus 50 more blocks plus nine blocks
or in total we have 22
hundred
fifty
nine blocks
moving on to this next one we know what
these different sizes represent
here this first or this column at the
end is ones
right beside it
these are columns of 10. we know those
are tens
then we don't have any of the hundreds
any of the where we had 10 sets of 10
making sort of like a flat slab we don't
have any hundreds in this number
but we do have these large cubes made up
of many many many small cubes and those
are thousands because they were 10 sets
of a hundred
so now let's count we have one two three
four five six seven eight ones
which is the same as eight
plus
one two three tens
thirty
plus no hundreds again
but
one two three thousands
which is three
thousand
so when we combine these numbers we need
to be careful to remember there are no
hundreds
our number will be three thousand
zero hundreds
and thirty
eight three thousand thirty eight
is the number represented by these place
value blocks
for this one i encourage you to pause
the video and see if you can figure out
on your own what number is represented
by the place value blocks
and now we can look at it together let's
remember this is ones
tens
hundreds
and
thousands
so looking at our ones we have one two
three four ones
four ones plus
one two tens which is twenty
ten plus ten is twenty plus now these
hundreds are several hundred let's see
100 200 300 400 500 600 700. there's
seven of the hundreds
plus only one of the thousands which
will be one
thousand
and now to combine this to write this
all together this will be one thousand
seven hundred twenty four
is the number shown with these place
value blocks